this video is sponsored by ubisoft and
if you enjoyed what you saw today use
the link in the description to pre-order
watch dogs legion now gentlemen today we
will be playing a game that's not even
out yet watch dogs legion and just so
you know this is a work in progress
build of the game oh
epic if you gentlemen will reach under
your keyboard you will find a piece of
paper with five challenges on it last
person to complete all five challenges
will get pelted with water balloons
filled with baked beans why the good old
triple b everyone unpause your game this
is watchdogs five challenges the four of
us this will be interesting gentlemen
move to your own call all right fine the
first challenge is while being a
hooligan defeat all the opponents in the
camden bare knuckle arena in watchdogs
you can play as anyone in london they
all have different abilities and
different things they can do i can be
this person that looks like she'll kill
you i could be a doctor i could be a
janitor who do you think has the best
skills in this jimmy i'm either gonna
guess construction guy or maybe grandma
grandma has a light machine gun the spy
guy allows you to go invisible you're
freaking crazy i've got the hooligan i'm
going to fight bare knuckle oh god i'm
on the wall he's on the ropes yeah get
out of here bro how many opponents are
there
why am i getting my butt kicked come on
come on oh headbutt to the face oh god
oh god finish him oh
we just curb stomping people in the face
oh
oh no this guy should be the easiest one
oh wait this guy has chains on his fist
that's the definition of not being bare
knuckles sir
i'm scared oh hey oh
finish him
yes sir i got her in the corner oh my
gosh you have to fight two guys on one
oh
oh i'm so good at this game i know how
to dodge now liz i know to dodge now
this guy's an absolute weenie
go get away no no no no no he's like one
hit away
i just keep beating people up i can't
stop
whoa oh that's right is it me versus
both of them oh but i'm over here now
oh i'm gonna break your friend's face
real quick and then i'll come back to
you
she put on a mask i don't know why oh
what all right now it's hard to see all
right you have to press y and you can
break your guard head butt him and then
kick him in the face then just stomp on
their face done
oh even though i can't see a still one
stop stop
just pounding me
okay i got one of them i got one of them
i can stop anybody i'd like now oh i can
save all of these and as you save people
you can build your own unique team of
resistance people oh i got all of them
they're all epic done with that
challenge number two deliberate freedom
fighters from the scotland yard while
playing as bobby who's bobby we need to
change to a bobby which i'm told
apparently means police officer oh well
i'm an officer dude the map is beautiful
oh i'm hacking the scotland yard i found
the scotland yard and now i'm a bobby oh
wait i can go invisible wait how do you
go invisible uh you know oh i think i
know what i'm gonna do
yeah i can
boy
i'm so sorry what oh heck no
oh hold on i'm gonna recruit her
i liberated the person hopefully i don't
get shot while i'm trying to liberate my
boy and now we're good you've been
rescued so at the rate we're going chris
is going to get pelted with big to be
fair we don't know where carl and
chandler are oh god i'm behind i just
don't want to get beaned on
come on lady you're coming with me okay
what am i doing heck a plane using a
drone expert at the civil aviation
where's civil aviation boom i can't find
civil aviation so i'm gonna skip to the
tower bridge we'll come back we gotta
climb to the top of it as a grandma is
that even possible stop taking selfies
we gotta hurry i found it yo full sprint
oh my god
all right i'm at the bridge i'm at the
bridge i'm at the bridge i'm at the
bridge i'm at the bridge granny granny
granny granny granny holy [ __ ]
the old lady said a cuss word yo
granny's so slow wait i gotta walk up
this whole building stairs and i have to
go up all of them i guess we're just
gonna go up this flights of stairs as an
old lady how'd you get in just open the
door jimmy
the door didn't open oh you want to try
and kill me i'm grandma with an again
where'd granny putting this machine gun
in i can't go inside the stairs and
all right we're in we're in right
now
oh
that's so cool okay while they're doing
that while they're distracted i'll have
that betray use that to distract all of
them
oh it didn't work
all right no granny now's not the time
to reload your smg please
oh cool i just get one-shotted granny
can you walk faster dude could you
imagine just seeing your grandma scaling
the side of it this has got to be the
top no look where i am i'm looking at
the exact same thing i'm at the top see
we're fine
i'm a hacker
i just can't get last i hijacked an
entire plane
oh challenge complete we did it i made
it to the top of the bridge look at the
view chris all right i climbed to the
top of the tower watch this
old lady job
okay i'm gonna take this boat i have to
hack a plane as a drone expert and then
complete the spiderbot mission all right
let's change to somebody who doesn't
move at one literal mile per hour please
move why do they drive on the wrong side
of the road all right drone expert climb
to the top of tower bridge using granny
as fast as you can tower bridge with
granny i'm just gonna go out on a limb
and say this is granny oh
i'm sorry granny
just run faster
yes jimmy uh what challenge are you on
carl i'm climbing to the top of the
tower with granny oh really i just
finished that one
bye i'm hacking a drone
get out of here
ah
i mean was there a way i was supposed to
not get killed there you're gonna hit an
old
lady
wow he was not playing
oh no
they killed granny i wonder
holy cow there's so many people at the
top
just stop punching her she's gonna wait
until my abilities back up
yeah
how about that let's try this again
all right now we interact with this yes
i got it wait ammo do i have guns
i have guns
oh honk where is it
is this like considered the top is this
the highest i can get and it's got to be
right the highest i can get right how do
i know if i made it to the top of the
tower i'll go to your computer and walk
you to the ladder if you show me oh carl
i already figured out fine you can have
chris help you so i'm supposed to hack
this oh it just lit the whole thing on
fire it's everything yep all right there
we go is this the highest i can yeah
that's the highest you can go
goodbye i gotta i gotta go then i gotta
hurry i gotta hurry i've had
confirmation that that was the top so
i'm going on okay so the fifth and final
one is complete the spiderbot mission
inside big bed okay i gotta find big ben
chris what's big ben it's a clock i just
wanted to trigger our english viewers do
you honestly think you're funny so now i
take over this spiderbot whoever
completes this big bin mission last gets
pelted with baked bean balloons let's
speed run it ooh
platform ring is my forte i'm scared of
spiders and clocks
this is crazy so i'm just walking around
big ben with the little spider oh my
gosh this is nerve-wracking oh
i thought it was going to strafe i think
this is the right way this looks like
the right way right
no no no no no no i messed up i messed
up big ben is crazy
that's crazy come on daddy needs to go
fast the leap of faith
duh the jump of death
pretty easy
let's go come on come on come on
no
i did the thing wait that was it the
fireworks yes i completed all five
challenges and i don't have to get big
beans all right let's check on the boys
all three of you are racing to the top
of big ben oh my god i'm the platforming
god oh
i think i'm here oh wait carl found it
no big fiends for me
i've never been so happy to see a spider
in my life it's now you versus chandler
where's chandler in retrospect to me uh
he's like a floor two above you
go how close am i you're going upwards
you're going in the right direction am i
close not as close as i am because i
already finished whoa i'm focusing so
hard oh no i fell
look don't hit me oh my god oh taylor
he's literally on the same floor as you
guys are right neck and neck boom i'm so
glad this thing can jump so good i'm
freaking i'm literally sweating the
controller's about to fall around my
hand oh wait is this your brother go go
go oh my gosh on the top if you do it
quick enough you won't get big being
ballooned what do i do what do i hit
keep running keep running i interact
let's go oh my god my hands
congratulations let's go see where chris
is guys hurry chandler's so far behind
am i done no chandler finished five
seconds ago
i'm taking a handful of beans and
craving them in water balloons you ready
chris
oh
bend your knees
if you enjoyed what you saw today use
the link in description to pre-order
watch dogs legion now